- Can you move your seat up?
No.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SEAT SQUEAKS]
Thing is, you don't have to.
I'm with you 'til the
end of the line, pal.
On your left.
Uh-huh.
On my left, got it.
Don't say it.
Don't you say it.
- On your left.
Come on!
Where's the fight?
Payload secure.
Thanks, Sam.
Don't thank me.
I'm not thanking that thing.
His name is Redwing.
BLACK WIDOW: I'm
still not thanking it.
He's cute.
Go ahead, pet him.
I didn't kill your father.
Then why did you run?
[THUDS]
[GRUNT]
[CRASH]
[GRUNTING]
[INTENSE MUSIC]
He's inside my pack.
Sorry.
Oh!
You seem like a
really great guy.
Ah, ah!
[CRASH]
It's really important to me that
Cap never finds out about this.
You couldn't have
done that earlier?
I hate you.
[CHIME]
[MUSIC PLAYING]